des travaux pour la rénovation urbaine
du quartier des musiciens aux mureaux
il fera partie d'un ensemble
l'écoquartier molière le quartier des
musiciens intégrera complètement cet éco
quartier et sera même le point de
jonction entre le parc que molière à qui
est la pierre angulaire verte de l'éco
quartier et le parc du sceau tour qui
situe de l'autre côté du quartier des
musiciens donc le quartier musicien va
être au centre à la jonction de ces deux
équipements verts est donc lui aussi
verdir a à cette occasion
objectif pour le bailleur les résidences
yvelines essonne réhabiliter la majeure
partie du quartier ont plusieurs étapes
environ 196 logements vont être démolis
723 vont être réhabilités la première se
mettre la démolition des trois tours
debussy qui représente 196 logements et
notre seconde intervention c'est la
réhabilitation de l'ensemble de notre
patrimoine restants qui correspond à 723
logements dans le cadre de cette
rénovation le département a lancé un
appel à projets priori blinn c'est un
programme de relance et d'investissement
pour le développement de l'offre
résidentielle
il permet au département d'accompagner
les collectivités qui développe des
projets de rénovation urbaine c'est la
communauté grand paris seine et ouest
qui a été sélectionné une candidate et
en 2017
ils ont inscrit de mémoire aux projets
11 secteurs venir nous en est tout aussi
bien le développement résidentiel que la
rénovation urbaine et les musiciens
faisait partie de cette candidature au
titre de la rénovation urbaine
le projet va s'échelonner de 2021 à 2028
coût total 110 millions d'euros